Alguma vez passou uma hora a fazer algo, só para descobrir que outra pessoa fazia em 10 minutos?
Isso acontece a todos nós.
Uma das formas mais rápidas de crescer é deixar de presumir que a sua forma é a melhor forma.
Em vez disso, faça uma pergunta simples.
Quem já faz isto melhor do que eu?
Essa pergunta pode poupar horas de trabalho, prevenir erros e ajudá-lo a crescer muito mais depressa.
As melhores pessoas do mundo não sabem tudo, sabem como aprender.
Pense em atletas profissionais.
Os maiores atletas continuam a ter treinadores.
Os maiores músicos continuam a ter professores.
Os maiores líderes empresariais continuam a pedir conselhos.
Por quê?
Porque a excelência deixa pistas.
Se alguém já resolveu um problema, aprenda com essa pessoa.
Não reinvente a roda.
Faça um benchmark.
Fazer benchmark significa encontrar o melhor exemplo e aprender com ele.
Talvez alguém na sua equipa escreva melhores e-mails.
Peça-lhe que ele mostre.
Talvez alguém organize melhor os ficheiros.
Pergunte-lhe como faz.
Talvez alguém seja ótimo com os clientes.
Observe como fala.
Talvez a IA possa ajudar.
Antes de enviar um e-mail, pergunte a IA.
Isto pode ficar mais claro?
Antes de criar um documento, pergunte.
Isto pode ficar mais simples?
Antes de resolver um problema, pergunte.
Há uma forma melhor?
Estas pequenas perguntas criam grandes melhorias ao longo do tempo.
Agora, aqui está algo importante.
Fazer benchmark exige humildade.
O orgulho diz, eu já sei.
A humildade diz, ensinem-me.
O orgulho impede a aprendizagem.
A humildade nunca deixa de crescer.
Não há vergonha em pedir ajuda.
Na verdade, pedir ajuda é muitas vezes um sinal de sabedoria.
Aqui está um exemplo simples.
Imagine duas pessoas a construir a mesma mesa.
A primeira pessoa começa imediatamente.
A segunda pessoa passa cinco minutos a pedir conselhos ao melhor carpinteiro.
A primeira pessoa trabalha quatro horas e comete erros.
A segunda pessoa trabalha três horas e produz uma mesa melhor.
Qual das duas pessoas foi mais produtiva?
A segunda.
Porque aprender primeiro poupa tempo depois.
Aqui está outro exemplo.
Está a fazer uma apresentação.
Em vez de adivinhar, peça a alguém que faz apresentações excelentes para rever.
Cinco minutos de feedback podem melhorar o seu trabalho em 50%.
Isso é fazer benchmark.
Lembre-se desta frase.
As pessoas boas trabalham com afinco.
As pessoas excelentes aprendem de pressa.
Na nossa empresa, queremos construir uma cultura onde pedir ajuda seja normal.
Partilhar conhecimento seja normal.
Aprender uns com os outros seja normal.
Porque quando uma pessoa melhora, toda a equipa melhora.
Por isso, esta semana, desafie-se.
Antes de começar uma tarefa importante, pergunte.
Quem faz isto melhor?
O que posso aprender com essa pessoa?
A IA pode ajudar-me a melhorar isto?
Nunca deixe de fazer benchmark.
Nunca deixe de aprender.
E nunca presuma que já encontrou a melhor forma.
Porque a excelência não é um destino, é um hábito.
Quanto mais aprende com a excelência, mais excelente se torna.